hallo mein name ist luca meine lieben
freunde gehabt wahrscheinlich schon am
gesamten können denn ich reagiere heute
mal wie auf eine neue episode zu heute
to handle wenn gespannt was diesmal
wieder so passieren wird ein neuer tag
wie die keiner kennt macht auch schon
meine damen und herren ich bin total
durch den wind
ich hab immer noch gefühle aber david
und ich brauche etwas sagen
ich befürchte dass jemand verletzt
werden könnte blieben freunde das honda
honda dated gerade zwei leute gleich für
den sieg jetzt hab ich empfinde etwas
voran dabei ich muss mit ihm reden
schließlich ist er mein freund das
stimmt ich du siehst gar nicht
verschlafen aus da wird auf einmal
komplett am musikalischen harry am
trainieren
ich liebe es wenn die lampe ich verstehe
nicht wie man auf eine lampe stehen kann
mit kate gerade wie oft er letzten acht
fasst die regeln gebrochen hätte gestern
im whirlpool was echt heiß der blick
sagt wieder alles das jetzt gilt meine
damen und herren und eigentlich brauche
ich gar nicht zu beginn jeder neuen
generation erklären wer wer ist oder er
hatte auf jeden fall letzten acht ein
date mit francesca die warmen whirlpool
und die haben nicht die regeln gebrochen
was ziemlich erstaunlich ist francesca
ziemlich heiser geschäft sehen wir mal
nach stehe auf solche spielchen und sie
ist echt gut darin mich jetzt definitiv
noch mehr
[Musik]
das war nicht euer ernst
dieses ding am zahn erinnert sich sigrid
mich jedes mal das gespräch mit pelz hat
mir nichts gebracht
er hat nicht gesagt was ich hören wollte
was wolltest du dann hört francesca und
kannst du dir bitte komplett aus der
show verpissen haley direkt mich so
geisteskrank auf jetzt hat mich mit
seinem verhalten besser als keine
[Applaus]
[Musik]
nur wird der rugby streit scheint die
tage des buchhalter sind gezählt denn
damals doch lieber eine regel gebrochen
da wäre ja zu gerne also nicht bei dir
schon aber am strand da gerade ich habe
das gefühl gleich sechs jemand in
bermuda liebesdreieck zwischen randers
david verein gehen
das betreffe narrenkappe wir sollten mal
reden ja hier sollte definitiv reden
denn er steht auf honda
der andere da auch und ronda weiß nicht
was sie will
da gibt's für mich ich bin single wien
pringle den blick treten könnten wäre
david himmer du bescheid mich ja werde
ich da sauer
naja du warst weder ehrlich noch nach
stimmt schon
da ist ja ganz wütend sieht man hier
auch hier wenn auch hier
ich finde es auch nicht gut was da wird
gemacht hat bin ich ganz ehrlich weil er
und schon kriegt es gut angefreundet und
schon ordentlich aufgeräumt aber dann
ist er wieder
wer die ganzen namen nie lernen was
gefühle für sie ruhig und hättest du im
workshop nicht gefällt bewusst ist dass
ich runter von anfang an gut fand und
gestern hatten wir endlich mal die
chance uns näher zu kommen
und er hier ist wieder wütend sieht man
hier an
auch hier oder hier und dem platz sieht
man es auch alle sind wütend da wird
also dass hier was einfallen hast du
romantische gefühle
diese antwort bitte was habe ich da
gerade von hohem ton getroffen
du hast gesagt du kannst dich ja nicht
öffnen dass ich hier von meiner
vergangenheit erzählt habe weiß doch
dass ich mich eröffnet
stimmt
stimmt guter punkt du siehst schon
wieder leicht wütend aus ja ich habe
gefühle füreinander aber das heißt nicht
dass ich nicht daran gedacht hätte die
es dir damit geht ja ihren mann
und egal wann die stoffe sind immer
komisch aus wenn du ernsthaft was für
ronda empfindest ziehe ich mich zurück
überlassen die das fest aber nur dann
wenn du weiter an die arbeit ist
er setzt dem ultimatum
und da sein und konnte mir noch ein reiz
macher und milch
nein er lacht er lächelt es geht grad ok
ich weise wieder freunde sehr gut
ich freue mich für eine gestellte
reality tv show mein leben ist echt
traurig red hat mir klar gemacht dass
sich um männer kämpfen ich also werde
ich weiter an mir arbeiten und mich
hassen hoffe ich hoffe dass ich nicht an
den falschen stellen
nicht dass noch einen regelverstoß
begangen wird aber irgendwie ist das das
einzige worauf ich glaube ich alle
warten
das ist auch richtig schön gossip reinen
die masse es gibt doris gespräch im café
stehst du hast gar nicht der schilder
einfach nur um gerade der trainiert
gerade nicht das ist kein problem von
jazz gab
mich würd ich stand falls du mal
irgendwie nach letzter nacht habe ich
nachgedacht ich habe einfach noch diese
unbewältigten gefühle ich denke es ist
das beste wenn wir auf die bremse treten
und er aufs gas tritt kommen noch köln
auch mein gott lukas reitz auch echt war
[Musik]
das ist sonne ehre man die ganzen ferien
scheiben
es war ein langes gespräch da inzwischen
so ist es gut kuscheln durch den schmerz
pumpen perfekt machen
ich komme ich ja auch mal durch den
schmerz alle zwei jahre wenn ich dann
mal im fitnessstudio lande
nachdem scharon sich wieder mit david
vertragen hat die planer ihn auf ein
date mit ronja hoben auch ihr seine
gefühle zu offenbaren
ich leide mit offenen karten spielen und
ihr sagen was ich fühle
ich setze eine gute idee
zweiten das ist eine ganz schwierige
beziehung irgendwie zueinander weil sie
hat voll bock aufgehen er hatte
allerdings stress mit seiner ex freundin
weil sie ihn mehrmals betrogen hat und
das wollte sie dann wieder gut machen
und dann hat er gesagt das geht mir sie
aber wiederum gesagt jedoch dass gehen
damit er wieder eine abfuhr erteilt wenn
man sie ja mit david haye wird es die
welle hier dann war da wird aber trotz
gesagt komm mach du und dann machst du
du du du du ruhen jetzt die beiden
ersten drei folgen in einer minute
zusammengefasst ich habe es leider noch
nicht gesagt aber ich werde mich
zurückziehen und die zwei machen lassen
ich glaube das hat jetzt selber gemerkt
ich glaube auch nicht dass roller sonst
irgendwie david dayton würde und dann
nebenbei noch schon mal so schätze ich
jetzt auch nicht auf dem papier ist
schülerin der idealen mann für mich aber
im gegensatz zu david kann er sich nicht
öffnen und seine gefühle zeigen wenn
sich das nicht ändert weiß ich echt
nicht mehr weiter schwierig also
papier ist der bessere aber emotional
gesehen da wird
dr
der bruder 3
sie tun
einfach sehr an das mit meiner extra
genannt wird es zwar nicht mein bester
freund aber wir sind echt decken
ihr seid echt zwei jungs die nicht nur
dicke sind sondern zwei jungs mit dicken
wow ich sollte echt wir mal so einen
humor buch kaufen für anfänger oder so
dieses verhalten macht ist ja nicht sehr
schwer da ist uns wird nichts wenn du
dich nicht öffnen
na ja so ist das eben wenn man jemanden
mag dieses mal guckt schon gar nicht mal
so schlecht
respekt schon kann so weitergehen ich
frage mich halt einfach nur mal so
generell also könnt ihr vielleicht auch
noch den kommentaren beantworten wie
viel aus dieser chance echt und wie viel
ist gefaked weil es fühlt sich so an als
wäre einfach alles gefällt weil immer
wenn die solche tieferen gespräche
führen hast du halt sieben verschiedene
kämmerer ein gallardo allerdings
einerseits die personen aus der
perspektive siehst und dann allerdings
im gleichen karte und therapie damit aus
der perspektive sieht man die kamera
hier nicht das heißt sie haben nicht
real die unterhaltung eingefangen
sondern das mehrmals aufgenommen checkte
wie ich mein so es ist alles fake
einfach das hat lange dabei gebracht
was hat langer den beigebracht bevor ich
herkam hätte ich nie gedacht dass das
hat leider uns beigebracht
im kurs kostet 3000 euro und im
schlafzimmer sind kameras angebracht es
fühlt sich merkwürdig aber auch gut an
ich schwöre dir hier und jetzt dass ich
versuchen werde mich zu öffnen worden
sweet
ich fühle die beiden
juli
für doch fand
natürlich nicht ich kann die tour jetzt
mal richtig ist dass den leuchtenden
zwei kein grünes licht bekommen kündige
ich will talk die haben diese buchen vor
und geloben zwei folgen oder so bekommen
das ist man auch nicht bei jedem wem was
habt ihr für schlechte entwicklung
ansteigen gelegt
mutter gottes der stelle ich meine
heutige reaktion auf tour zu händel
jetzt allerdings auch beenden meine
lieben freunde wenn es euch gefallen hat
dann das gerne einen daumen hoch unter
dem video hier das schaffen wir in
60.000 drei unserem letzten video haben
wir glaube ich 50.000 like sei geschafft
also 60.000 wir auf jeden fall nach
hausnummern wird mir zeigen jo ihr
feiert und denn ihr das auch feiert und
folgt auf instagram es erhöht meine
chance dass sich francesca anschreiben
dass wir die em 4
allerdings befinden wir uns jetzt auch
schon in der endart meine lieben freunde
hier oben ist das weil ich eingeblendet
werden noch kein abonnent von einem
kanal sei dann klingt da gern drauf denn
ist kostenlos und verpasst keine videos
mehr wenn ihr schon aber dann klickt auf
die glocke denn dann bekommt er eine
benachrichtigung auf euer handy sobald
ich ein neues video hochladen und ihr
seid direkt der hand gucken kann der ist
ein anderes video verlinkt so klingt
auch gern drauf